Shakespeare's leadership power is about
all the teaching that his characters do
by conscious explicit example or by the
way not to do it think about the scene
in Henry v where the king is on his way
to Agincourt everyone's sick and they're
way outnumbered and one of his old
drinking buddies when he was Prince how
Bhargav is caught stealing from a church
and so Henry has to make this very
machine decision but what he's gonna do
with his friend he's gonna let him off
as pistol one of his other drinking
buddies is begging him to or is he going
to sending sample as a leader of what
people who violate the code of behavior
do and he hangs him he decides to hang
him but there the teaching is in the
actual action right and by virtue of you
can't mess with the mission folks or you
know you'll have to be sacrificed right
the the costs of violation are high and
so you think about what that must have
cost Henry the fifth and how great his
leap has been from the young prince the
hooligan to the warrior king and their
Shakespeare teaching by action and
example and including negative example